NEW BORDER WALL CONSTRUCTION AND
VERY POWERFUL PRESENTATION
BRINGING IN GLORIA AND OTHER
EXPERTS ON THE GROUND.
ONE OF THE GUYS SAID IF YOU ARE
DENYING IT IS CRISIS ON THE
BORDER, NOT ONLY ARE YOU BEING
DISHONEST, YOU ARE BEING
DISHONEST WITH MALICE.
>> MALICE IS GREAT WORD WHEN
USED PROPERLY.
IS SOMETHING ABOUT FEET ON THE
GROUND, PEOPLE LIVING IN THE
MOMENT.
WHAT WAS STARTING TO GO SOUTH, I
THINK THE PRESIDENT WAS GETTING
A LOSS FOR WORDS THERE.
HE BROUGHT GLORIA IN, PHENOMENAL
JOB.
PEOPLE CAN FEEL THAT, THEY
UNDERSTAND THAT.
TAKE THE POLITICS OUT AND GO
WITH FACTS AND WHAT IS GOING ON
THERE, THAT WAS BIPARTISAN
STRAIGHT UP, THIS IS HOW IT IS,
HOW WE ARE DEALING WITH IT, THAT
IS WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED
TO SEE.
THAT WAS GREAT INFORMATION, IF
YOU HAD ISSUES WERE LISTENING TO
STUFF GOING ON IN WASHINGTON,
AFTER SEEING THAT INTERVIEW, YOU
WOULD START THINKING, MAYBE
THERE IS SOMETHING GOING ON, NOT
JUST HYPERBOLY.
YOUR PR WAS BOILING.
>> PUMPING.
>> GREAT HATS.
>> WHEN YOU HAVE A HAT LIKE
THIS.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, I'M LEARNING A
LOT.
>> I MIGHT HAVE TO GET ONE LIKE
THAT, PEOPLE LISTEN WHEN YOU
WEAR A HAT.
>> MESS UP THE HAIR.
JUAN, YOU HEARD FROM THE PEOPLE
ON THE GROUND, ROCK THROWING
DOWN 65%.
WHEN DEPLOYED STRATEGICALLY, IT
IS VERY EFFECTIVE.
>> Juan: YEAH, THANK YOU
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
THAT SECTION OF WALL WAS PAID
FOR BACK IN 2009 AS REPAIR JOB
BY GUESS WHO, PRESIDENT OBAMA.
>> ACTUALLY WE PAID FOR IT,
TAXPAYERS.
>> I'M SAYING RIGHT NOW, YOU
LISTEN TO THIS BLUSTER AND BLUFF
COMING FROM TRUMP.
OH, IS TRUMP PUTTING UP THAT
WALL?
TRUMP HASN'T BUILT ANY WALL,
THIS IS REPAIR JOB FUNDED BY
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
LOOK, I THINK DANA HAS A POINT,
ALWAYS GOOD TO GET OUT OF
WASHINGTON.
>> Dana: LET ME HEAR MORE ABOUT
THE POINT.
>> Juan: I'LL TELL YOU,
IMPORTANT FOR HIM TO GET OUT.
HE'S BEING SUED BY 20 STATES,
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA OVER
EMERGENCY DECLARATION.
THEY ARE ASKING FOR HIS TAX
RETURNS AND HE'S STRUGGLING WITH
THAT ONE.
JUST TODAY HE WITHDREW
NOMINATION OF HIS ICE DIRECTOR,
GUY UP FOR THAT JOB.
NOBODY IS CLEAR ON IT, EXCEPT
THINKING STEVEN MILLER, WHO IS
BEHIND THIS, FAILED IMMIGRATION
POLICY, DIDN'T LIKE THE GUY.
OF COURSE THE SENATE --
>> Jesse: JUAN, YOU SAID SINCE
IT IS OBAMA'S WALL, YOU LIKE IT?
>> Juan: NO, WHAT I SAID WAS,
NO, NO, YOU GUYS FOCUS ON THE
IDEA THAT YOU HAD SECURITY
PEOPLE SAYING BEFORE THIS WALL
WAS HERE WE HAD A -- GUESS WHAT,
THAT IS BEFORE THE WALL WAS
THERE YEARS AGO.
JE
>> Jesse: YOU ARE SAYING WALLS
WORK?
>> Juan: WE DON'T NEED TO SEE
THE SHINING SEA WALL EXCEPT IN
YOUR IMAGINATION.
>> Jesse: WE NEED TO STRATEGE
>> Jesse: WE NEED TO STRATEICA
STRATEGICALLY, RIGHT?
>> Dana: WE DO.
REAL-WORLD APPLICATION GOING ON
THAT CROSSES BORDERS, THE CRISIS
IS NOT LIMITED TO NOR DOES IT
BEGIN AT SOUTHERN BORDER.
ONE GENTLEMAN MENTIONED $50
BILLION OVER AND ACROSS PORTS OF
ENTRY, ALMOST 30 BILLION IS
PROFIT FROM THE -- FOR CARTEL
AND DRUG INDUSTRY.
SINCE 2006, MEXICO HAS BEEN
FIGHTING MILITARILY STRATEGY
AGAINST ALL DRUG WARS LOCALLY.
WHAT DO WE THINK WE ARE SEEING?
IT IS ALL THE EFFECTS FROM THAT.
NOT ABOUT SIMPLY HUMAN
IMMIGRATION CROSSING SOUTHERN
BORDER, THE PUSH FACTOR IS
COMING SOUTH OF THE BORDER ARE
SO STRONG AND COMPLICATED AND SO
NOW LONG-TERM INVESTED THAT IS
WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH.
I LOVE THE PRESIDENT BROUGHT IN
BROADER CONVERSATION OF
INCLUDING MEXICO IN THAT, IT IS
ABOUT TIME FOR SOME DIPLOMACY,
EITHER HELP OR STOP IT.
>> IMPORTANT TO HEAR THE GRIZZLY
REALITY OF THE DRUG WAR, TALKING
ABOUT THEY FIND 100 BODIES A
YEAR BURIED IN THE DESERT.
>> SO THE PRESIDENT, I WOULD
KEEP HIM OUT ON THE ROAD ONCE A
WEEK.
WHEN YOU ARE IN THE ROOSEVELT
ROOM OR THE CABINET ROOM AND
BRING THE CAMERAS IN OR SAY HE'S
HEADED TO MAR-A-LAGO ON FRIDAY
AND TALKS TO THE CAMERAS ON THE
WAY OUT TO THE HELICOPTER, IT
LOOKS REPETITIVE.
YOU HAVE TO CHANGE THE SCENE TO
CHANGE THE STORY LINE.
THE I ALSO THINK EVERYDAY THIS
WEEK HE'S HAD A DIFFERENT
POSITION ON MEXICO.
THERE WAS GOING TO BE CLOSING
THE BORDER, THEN NOT CLOSING THE
BORDER, TARIFFS, THEN NOT FOR A
YEAR.
TODAY HE'S PRAISING THE MEXICAN
PRESIDENT, MAYBE THAT WORK
NECESSARY TERMS OF GETTING THE
MEXICAN PRESIDENT TO DO MORE.
I WOULD DO THIS, WE KNOW THE
ANSWER TO PROBLEMS RESIDES IN
CONGRESS.
FOCUS LIKE LASER BEAM ON
CONGRESS, BUT MAKE THEM FOLLOW
YOU.
GET OUT THERE, GET ON THE BORDER
OR WHEREVER, TALK ABOUT
HEALTHCARE, WHEREVER IT IS GOING
TO BE, DON'T DO IT FROM THE
ROOSEVELT ROOM, IT IS NOT
EFFECTIVE.
>> DO YOU THINK THIS IS A
GAME-CHANGER TO GET ON THE ROAD,
CHANGE THE OPTICS AND FORCE,
MAYBE A DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN
OR SENATOR TO VISIT AND HEAR
FROM THE EXPERTS?
>> GO BACK TO GLORIA, PHENOMENAL
JOB.
IT CHANGED THE CONVERSATION,
FROM JUAN'S EXPRESSION, HERE WE
GO AGAIN TO WHAT IS SHE TALKING
ABOUT, IT IS INTERESTING.
IMPORTANT TO WHAT WE NEED.
FLIP FLOP THROUGH THE STORY.
I WOULD SAY, JESSE WATTERS HAIR
IS OFF TO THE RIGHT, I DON'T
LIKE IT.
IT IS OFF TO THE LEFT, MAYBE YOU
SHOULD CHANGE IT.
IT IS OFF TO THE LEFT.
HE IS LISTENING TO HIS PEOPLE.
HE IS CRITICIZED FOR NOT, HE
WILL SAY SOMETHING, IF WE CLOSE
THE BORDER, THE ECONOMY WILL BE
IN BIG TROUBLE.
OKAY, YOU GOT A YEAR.
I'M OKAY WITH THAT, HE'S KNOWN
FOR GOING OFF THE CUFF, KNOWN
FOR GETTING EMOTIONAL.
WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS.
HE IS LISTENING TO THE EXPERTS.
>> IT TAKES FOCUS OFF CONGRESS.
>> THAT IS WHAT THEY WANT.
NO ONE AT THIS TABLE HAS A
CONGRESS TISSUIN
CONGRESS  TSSUIN
CONGRESS  THFUIN
CONGRESS  THFRIN
CONGRESS  THFR N
CONGRESS  THFR SHIRT?
>> WHO POLITICIZED THIS ISSUE IN
THE FIRST PLACE?
DONALD TRUMP SAID MEXICO WAS
GOING TO PAY FOR THIS.
FORGET THAT FOR A SECOND.
REMEMBER SPENDING ON A WALL DOES
NOTHING TO STOP INFUSION OF
FAMILIES AND ESPECIALLY FAMILIES
WITH CHILDREN, NOT TALKING ABOUT
INVASION, WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
MOST OF THE PEOPLE COMING NOW,
FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN.
WALL HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THAT.
IT DOES NOTHING IN TERMS OF THE
AD ADDED WALL, IN TERMS OF
DETENTION FACILITIES NEEDED TO
ACCOMMODATE THESE PEOPLE AT THIS
MOMENT, THAT IS THE CRISIS, THE
REAL CRISIS.
>> THE FAMILIES ARE PAWNS ARE
THE CARTELS.
THAT IS A SMALL PORTION.
>> THIS IS NOT MOSTLY MEXICAN,
THEY ARE COMING FROM CENTRAL
AMERICA.
THERE ARE DIFFERENT RULES.
>> THAT IS WHY I FOCUS ON
CONGRESS AND FIX THAT PART.
>> DEMOCRATS WANT TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THE FACILITY,
DETENTION FACILITIES.